Mr President it's good to see you again
Delight to be with you and uh you know
we're this historic Summit meeting we're
resolving a lot of things I hope and
yeah
we made uh we made uh all the more
restored by the agreement you reached
yesterday in the edition of Sweden
that's your president America well after
seeing that uh performance I suppose
it's no surprise that Biden decided to
skip tonight's dinner with NATO leaders
and it's not the first time an axios
report by Alex Thompson pointed out it's
the third time this has happened the New
York Times reporting last month that
after fatiguing Days on the Road he
skipped dinner with world leaders in
Indonesia last year and again in Japan
this past May
but the facade is already being built
around the octogenarian President Biden
campaign co-chair Jeffrey katzenberg
telling Politico that the lack of a
campaign apparatus so far it's no
accident right now he said we have a
fine-tuned race car here at some point
we will build out a big substantial
competitive organization and Enterprise
we don't need to do that today it would
literally be a waste of money
heard it right folks the man that you
saw barely able to move a two pound
beach chair of the weekend is really a
fine-tuned race car
we're used to katzenberg being behind
hit films but now he's taking on the
Epic disaster film The Water World the
political campaigns here now is Molly
Hemingway editor-in-chief of the
Federalist and Charlie heard opinion
editor of the Washington Times both are
Fox News contributors Molly you know
it's our last few days at 10 o'clock we
get a little cheeky as the night goes on
but
I mean it is funny but it is not sitting
there looking at the cards it's not he's
struggling to read a note card
this is our president and they act like
if they just say that everything's fine
that the American people will think that
everything's fine there's a truth here
though that the campaign might you might
say it's being run fine and that's
because really the corporate media run
the Biden campaign that's what they did
in 2020. remember he barely campaigned
and when he did it with an epic disaster
and yet the media did such a good job of
running it for him they're probably just
counting on the media doing it again
should he be the nominee yeah Charlie I
think Molly raises a good point I mean
look why hire a staff you have a staff
over at you know the other networks and
the New York Times Washington Post Etc
why do you really need to build out an
organization that would actually
indicate that he was going to campaign
yeah you have a you have a complete
political arm in every Newsroom in
America uh it seems
um and I do think that they sort of uh
are under the impression that they can
run the same campaign they ran last time
they think that Donald Trump is going to
be the nominee and all they have to do
is sit back and let the media take care
of the campaign for them but I I think
that Molly is exactly right that's not
going to work you can lie to people only
so much and at some point you know you
can't a voter can't unsee Biden uh
dragging the the beach chair struggling
to drag the beach chair across the beach
or you can't unsee him falling down on
the stage at the Air Force commencement
um whose idea was that I mean can I I'm
sorry to interrupt you Molly
idea was that to put him
on a beach without a shirt on nobody
needs to see it and she looks fine I
guess I mean it's nothing wrong with
that but it's a little odd it's odd
nobody wants to see it and it does make
you wonder if there's some sort of
sabotage going on inside of Biden White
House also with some of the stories that
have come out recently about him you
know we all know that he's had a temper
for a long time but people speaking more
openly about his struggles you know even
just publicly once again not doing this
dinner I mean I'm actually not opposed
to that too because we all know that if
you were if you were operating to get
rid of mine it'll be easy to have to say
what is he going to go defend himself in
Ohio I mean I mean so they don't think
they have to be cute if they want to get
rid of them but I agree with you it's a
little curious but Charlie Bloomberg
investigative reporter Jason Leopold
filed a foia request for more records
into that White House cocaine Scandal
and of course his request was swiftly
denied the Secret Service says it can't
release any records because it would
interfere with enforcement proceedings
yeah this all sounds like a familiar
patter doesn't it the ongoing
investigation prevents us right and it's
exactly like the never-ending
investigations into Hunter Biden so that
they don't don't ever if you never have
to close the investigation you never
have to answer any questions about it
and it's you know all the more uh you
know important for Republicans to uh
press to get all of these things and I
think that they should they should play
hardball in terms of holding everything
up in Congress until they get answers to
these and Molly to that point
someone lied in this Hunter Biden
investigation it was either Merrick
Garland or someone else is lying and if
mayor Garland lied before Congress
is that not a bigger deal than the
zielinski phone call that Trump had that
they impeached him over there are so
many issues I could play here with how
the Biden family business investigation
was handled we have so many
whistleblowers alleging that when they
were trying to run down the situation
that they were blocked by different
people we do definitely have a conflict
between what the U.S attorney wise has
said and what Merrick Garland has said
they definitely need to clarify this
there's clearly someone's not telling
the truth here but the bottom line is
really that we all know what happened
here with this investigation was that
Hunter Biden gets a sweetheart deal they
ring up all of their political enemies
on the slightest of charges they find
reasons to go after them and with their
political friends they protect them and
they give them deals that the rest of us
would never dream of yeah they're so
concerned about the rule of law Trump
was just a wrecking ball against the
rule of law they said who who's the
wrecking ball now yeah you know and you
know it's sort of a tired talking point
but I think it is important you know if
just imagine if any of these things had
happened under Trump Administration it
would be a whole different and the media
would be treating it all I'd never let
it go now Molly I mentioned zelensky
earlier but he went after Biden for
rejecting Ukraine's NATO membership
tweeting earlier this morning that it's
unprecedented and absurd when time frame
is not set this means that a window of
opportunity is being left to bargain
Ukraine's membership in NATO
negotiations with Russia and for Russia
this means motivation to continue its
Terror uncertainty is weakness
Molly um
I'm not a lot of gratitude there for the
American people forking over what is it
totally about 200 billion dollars and
Counting right I mean he might be trying
this approach because it's actually
worked for him thus far everything
lecturing us everything he asks for or
demands Biden supplies that to him the
problem is that we have a very serious
situation here ukrainians are dying the
country is being destroyed and the
United States which used to serve a role
as a kind of Statesman role where they
could work to resolve these conflicts is
instead actually exacerbating the
situation in some cases and just not
providing any leadership kerosene on the
fire perhaps well and there are there
are other countries that could come in
and provide that leadership and we don't
you know that we can't really afford
this right now there's not a lot of
strategic thinking about the you know
the nature of this conflict and how
investing so much and giving so much
there has left us vulnerable and also
how it has left us unprepared for bigger
greater threats a world away yeah as
we're seeing in China Mali and Charlie
thank you both and thank you for being
so wonderful at 10 o'clock you'll even
be better at seven o'clock great to see
you both hey Sean Hannity here here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else